[Musik]
Preise steigen wirtschaftsschrumpft wird
Deutschland immer
ärmer und damit einen guten Abend liebe
Zuschauer 22 Uhr 16 haben wir es und es
ist gut dass sie wieder mit dabei sind
die Inflation ist ein zähes Biest das
hat nicht nur der Bundesfinanzminister
festgestellt sondern auch jeder Bürger
der auch seinen Kassenzettel im
Supermarkt schaut ein Handwerker braucht
oder einfach Gas und Strom verbraucht
und dieses Biest könnte bleiben denn uns
fehlen auch Arbeitskräfte und
Produktivität und andere wichtige Dinge
viele befürchten nun dass der Wohlstand
in Deutschland singt wird das Land also
immer ärmer oder lässt sich das
aufhalten wie uns die ampelregierung
verweist wir müssen reden mit diesen
Gästen
der
spd-generalsekretär Kevin Kühnert
Carsten Linnemann stellvertretender
CDU-Vorsitzender
die Autorin Julia Friedrichs
der Ökonom Daniel Stelter
der britische Wirtschaftshistoriker Adam
tools
und Claudia jeschkowski
Personalberaterin verheiratet zwei
kleine Kinder
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt die Gäste der Sendung noch
mal ausgesprochen herzlich Inflation
eine hässliches Wort wird in Deutschland
gerade durchbuchstabiert und die
Regierung liebe Zuschauer versucht die
Lage schön zu reden
[Musik]
ein bisschen langsamer aber
Lebensmittelpreise stiegen im Mai um
fast 15%
. da tröstet kaum dass die
Inflationsrate zuletzt auf 6,1% gesunken
ist
Energiepreise auch Lebensmittelpreise
gehen deutlich runter lange nicht mehr
selbst eingekauft der Robert
in zwei Jahren kletterten Preise für
Heizöl um 32 und Erdgas um
133%. und was eine Familie in den
letzten zwei Jahren beim Einkaufen im
Geldbeutel spürt ist sehr real
[Musik]
Julia Friedrichs ist bei uns
Journalistin Autoren Frau Friedrichs sie
befassen sich journalistisch mit den
Menschen die tatsächlich nicht wirklich
viel im Portemonnaie haben
wer leidet jetzt am allermeisten unter
diesem Preissteigerungen unter diesen
Teuerung ja das Problem ist dass die
Inflation vor allem nur unsoziale
Inflation ist wir haben gerade gesehen
die Lebensmittelpreise gehen hoch die
Energiepreise das sind ausgerechnet die
Dinge die Menschen mit geringem
Einkommen für dieses den großen Teil
ihres Budgets ausgeben müssen
gezwungenermaßen und die Menschen die
ich begleitet habe ich erinnere mich z.B
dass ich jetzt ein Jahr eine
Briefzustellerin begleitet habe die hat
schon bei unseren ersten Treffen vor
einem Jahr immer beim Essen sehr sehr
gespart die wusste auf Tour wenn sie auf
brieftour ist sie darf auf keinen Fall
Hunger bekommen sie kann sich nie einen
sandwichen Kaffee to go leisten das war
quasi der alte Zustand von einem Jahr da
hat sie immer Porridge gegessen in der
Frühstückspause weil das so lange satt
macht damit sie keinen Hunger bekommt
als ich sie jetzt wieder getroffen habe
hat sie gesagt
sie hat jetzt die Sparschraube noch
weiter gedreht und kommt jetzt langsam
in Zustande wo es nicht mehr weitergeht
das heißt konkret kein Fleisch kein
Fisch sie hat immer abends gern ein
Stück Käse mal mit Weintrauben gegessen
gestrichen sie fängt jetzt an auch auf
Mahlzeiten zu verzichten als wir sie mit
der Kamera begleitet haben hat sie war
ihr Abendessen zum Beispiel ein Quark
mit ein bisschen Obst ja aus dem aus dem
Tütchen quasi und ich glaube das sind
die Menschen um die es eigentlich gehen
muss ich würde sagen das sind vielleicht
das untere Drittel die unteren 40% der
Bevölkerung das sind die Menschen die
jetzt langsam nicht mehr ein und aus
wissen weil schon lange sparen also all
die Tricks sie sagt auch immer wenn sie
die Tricks in der Zeitung liest was man
jetzt alles machen kann das macht sie eh
schon abends in die Supermärkte gehen
weil da auf die Sachen runtergelassen
sind natürlich nur nach Angebot kaufen
sie sagt sie kauft nach Lust und Laune
kauft sie ohnehin schon seit Jahren
nicht mehr im Winter hat sie nur einen
Raum jetzt und sich noch eine Decke
zusätzlich gekauft das heißt da ist
einfach nichts mehr da was man noch
einsparen könnte und ich glaube das ist
die Gruppe die man im Fokus haben sollte
die haben auch eine Lehrerin begleitet
also nur um auch deutlich zu machen die
tatsächlich auch in einer staatlichen
Institution arbeitet und auch die kamen
schon nicht mehr über den Monat weil sie
nicht fest angestellt war genau das ist
so die Macht Integrationskurse Deutsch
als Zweitsprache also Menschen die wir
gerade ganz ganz dringend brauchen für
wichtige Aufgaben das hat haben wir
leider so organisiert dass die nur pro
gegebener Stunde bezahlt werden das
heißt extrem prekär und auch bei ihr war
es so dass sie gesagt hat ich weiß
langsam echt nicht mehr was ich machen
soll ich überlege ob ich mir zwei Job in
der Gastro suche da gibt's dann
wenigstens Trinkgeld die Leute werden
gesucht also ich erlebe wie gesagt
gerade die untere Mittelschicht bei
meinen Recherchen auch Reinigungskräfte
habe ich lange begleitet als Menschen
die extremst unter Druck stehen Kevin
Kühnert ist bei uns der SPD 32 Grad Herr
Kühnert man weiß nicht so richtig wo man
anfangen soll vielleicht ich versuche es
mal so lang 13 Wochen Streit um die
berühmte Heizung und da sind Menschen
vielleicht aus ihrem Blick geraten die
klassisch zum Klientel auch der SPD
gehören müsse um die sich die SPD auch
kümmern müsste
sind die ihnen irgendwie durchs
rausgefahren ich verstehe auch so einen
Satz wie den von Robert habe ich nicht
wirklich zu sagen die Preise sind doch
dramatisch gesunken und dann stellt man
fest sie sind immer noch zwei stellig
also ja hier ist die Frage wie kommt man
auf so ein Bild gut also beim Thema
Heizung da brauchen wir jetzt nicht
lange drüber diskutieren da werden wir
keinen Preis mehr für Gewinn für die
Debatten der letzten Wochen trotzdem
will ich schon zurückweisen dass wir in
dieser Zeit Leute vergessen hätten wir
schaffen schon mehrere Themen
gleichzeitig und die Normen Inflation
ist ja auch nicht vor zehn Wochen
entstanden sondern die begleitet uns
jetzt schon deutlich länger insbesondere
Energiepreis getrieben im vergangenen
Jahr deswegen schlägt es ja bei Leuten
mit kleineren Einkommen so stark durch
denn das was ein Haushalt mit wenig
Einkommen unvermeidbar ausgeben muss
Lebensmittel wohnungswärme und Mobilität
das sind die Sachen die über diesen
sechs sieben Prozent gestiegen sind
weshalb das dort richtig durchschlägt
wir haben das ja wissen sie mit
verschiedenen Maßnahmen versucht so gut
es geht erstmal abzufedern vor allem mit
den energiepreisbremsen die ja jetzt
gerade im Moment greifen und wirken mit
der Möglichkeit Steuer und abgabenfreie
Einmalzahlung zwischen Arbeitgeber und
Arbeitnehmer zu schaffen und vielen
anderen Maßnahmen mehr Kindergeld
Erhöhungen wohngeldausweitung
steuerliche Erleichterung all das war
drin aber der Sozialdemokrat wird Ihnen
natürlich auch immer antworten dass bei
dauerhaft höheren Preisen auch wenn es
sich jetzt ein bisschen normalisiert ist
dann auch die Aufgabe der nächsten der
aktuellen Lohnrunden ist der kriegen das
ja in den Nachrichten alle mit heute bei
der Bahn wo die EVG jetzt längerfristig
in den Streit gehen wird es ist dann
auch die Aufgabe von solchen lohnUntern
den Beschäftigten Deutschland ihren
gerechten Anteil an unserem Wohlstand
auch zu geben noch mal die Frage wenn
Robert Habeck sagt dass die Preise jetzt
dramatisch gesunken sind die Präsidentin
des Statistischen Bundesamtes sagt im
Mai seit letztem Jahr im Vergleich sind
die Nahrungsmittel zweistellig wieder
gestiegen sie bleiben der stärkste
Preistreiber wie kannten Vizekanzler das
Gegenteil davon behaupten also ist es
noch Bezug zur Wirklichkeit wie soll man
dazu sagen ich sitze jetzt nicht als ein
Sprecher hier aber ich kann für die
Koalition insgesamt sagen wir Wissen
darum dass die Dinge deutlich teurer
sind als im letzten Jahr ich vermute ich
kenne das Zitat jetzt auch in diesem
Ausschnitt dass er darauf Bezug genommen
hat dass einzelne Produktgruppen das
habe ich auch gelesen nun wieder runter
ging das berühmte von Butter ist zuletzt
ein bisschen günstiger geworden es
ändert aber überhaupt nichts daran dass
der Sockel auf dem wir uns preislich
befinden höher ist als das in den
letzten Jahren war und ja übrigens auch
bleiben wird denn Energiepreise die Ver
gleichsweise hoch sind gerade solange
wir noch ein fossilen Zeitalter
unterwegs sind die werden uns noch die
ganzen nächsten Jahre begleiten ist das
nicht eine kurze Episode sondern eine
grundsätzliche Herausforderung neben
Ihnen sitzt Daniel stellte makroökonom
autorunternehmensberater Hersteller die
Inflation ist neben dem Klimaschutz war
das was die Menschen momentan am meisten
bewegt und man kann natürlich auch sagen
besorgt
gibt es etwas was die Politik möglichst
schnell tun kann um Ihnen diese Sorge zu
nehmen
also zum einen möchte ich mal betonen
jede Inflation ist und sozial also es
ist keine besondere Inflation Inflation
trifft immer die unteren
Einkommensschichten am härtersten und
deshalb rufen wir etwas dagegen tun
ist gerade eben wo hat der Kühnert
gesagt naja wir müssen quasi aus dem
fossilen Zeitalter daraus dann gibt es
Hoffnung was Energiepreise betreffen und
dauert ganz ehrlich sagen das stimmt
einfach nicht ich meine sogar die Touchs
die ja nicht gerade berühmt dafür ist
dass sie nie und liberale Thesen
vertritt hatten Kommentar festgestellt
wir müssen einfach damit rechnen die
Energiepreise werden deutlich weiter
steigen weil die Energiewende sehr teuer
ist insofern brauchen wir grundlegende
Antworten und sie haben geschildert von
der Postboten das kann ich total gut
nachvollziehen wir haben ein ganz
anderes Problem wir werden ja nicht
jetzt ärmer sondern wir sind schon
länger ärmer geworden haben sie nicht
wahrgenommen warum wir haben zwar einen
Aufschwung erlebt bis Corona aber diese
Aufschwung war nicht getragen von mehr
Produktivität Produktivität heißt dass
wir pro Stunde mehr erwirtschaftet haben
dass sie Einkommen pro Stunde gewachsen
sind sondern wir haben mehr Menschen
beschäftigt und wenn sie keine Produkt
qualitätszuwächse haben dann wächst der
Kuchen nicht wenn der Kuchen nicht
wächst können Sie den nicht besser nicht
leicht verteilen wachsenden Kuchen
können Sie leichter verteilen als ein
Kuchen der Stadt geht oder gerade
schrumpft weshalb eben
Verteilungskonflikte massiv zunehmen
werden das heißt die eigentliche Antwort
die die Politik geben müsste wäre zu
sagen wie schaffen wir es unser Land
wieder voran zu bringen und jetzt noch
einfügen darf wir haben ja das Problem
dass wir seit 20 Jahren das Land auf
Verschleiß gefahren haben alle Daten
zeigen das Investitionen Investition
sowohl öffentlich wie auch privat der
Kapital Stock Deutschlands ist für
stärker alt der alte Schule verteilt hat
wie keinen anderen Land stärker als in
Italien und wir sind jetzt total
überziehen genau
Infrastruktur also Straßen
Telefonnetze aber auch die
maschinenanlagengebäude sind so starker
Alter die in keinem anderen
vergleichbaren Land und wir sind jetzt
hinter Italien hinter Frankreich hinter
Belgien
Großbritannien und das ist die Grundlage
und darum diese Regierung eigentlich
daran arbeiten wenn wir jetzt aber
hingehen und stattdessen nicht nur ein
Beispiel sagen Geld geht eine Frage
nochmal also nach Inflation große Sorge
der deutschen aber die Grundlage die
Grundlage dafür dass das Problem haben
ist dass wir in der Vergangenheit schon
nicht genug Wohlstand geschaffen haben
und was sollte die Regierung machen ich
gebe ihnen einfach was sie nicht machen
sollte sie fördert jetzt in in Magdeburg
in Zell ein US-Konzern der Gewinner
macht mit 10 Milliarden das sind über 3
Millionen pro Arbeitsplatz das sind
übrigens von jedem Bürger und jeder
Bürgerin in diesem Land vom Baby bis zum
Rentner 120 €. dieses Geld sollte nicht
dafür ausgegeben werden soll dafür
ausgegeben werden die Straßen repariert
werden dass die Schulen repariert werden
dass das Lampe modernisieren und dass
wir damit die Basis dafür haben dass sie
Produktivität die Produktivität wächst
und damit auch die Einkommen
entsprechend wachsen können das heißt
wir können uns nicht in Wohlstand
subventionieren und wir können uns auch
nicht die Inflation wecken
subventionieren das können wir gar nicht
bezahlen
einfach zu fragen warum die Regierung
das getan hat und sogar richtig stolz
darauf ist mit dieser Ansiedlung nach
Sachsen-Anhalt bekommen zu haben Kassen
Linnemann ist bei uns Linnemann sie
haben das Grundsatzpapier der CDU
erarbeitet und können uns bei der
Beantwortung der Frage helfen jeder
fünfte Bürger ist unzufrieden mit der
ist nur noch zufrieden mit der Arbeit
der Bundesregierung erst eins bis vier
davor sind nicht zufrieden mit der
Arbeit der Bundesregierung warum schlägt
das eigentlich nicht auf die Union über
warum partizipieren sie nicht davon dass
wir eine handwerklich kämpfende und
ansonsten viel streitende
Bundesregierung haben
vor anderthalb Jahren eine
Bundestagswahl verloren weil wir nicht
mehr gut genug waren wir haben Vertrauen
verloren in der Bevölkerung das können
sie nicht von heute auf morgen wieder
aufbauen und mal eben hochgehen in den
Umfragen der Sebastian Kurz hat dass man
mit der LVP geschafft der ging schnell
auf 40 und dann so schnell wieder runter
deswegen macht es Sinn dass man das
Vertrauen vernünftig aufbaut und dass
wir jetzt ein Programm machen dass die
Leute auch ernst nehmen und Wissen
wieder was ist denn wenn ich das Kreuz
bei der CDU mache was erwartet mich dann
und diese Herausforderung jetzt
sehe ich weniger sogar als Politiker
mehr als Ökonom
wir hatten Inflation in der Geschichte
dass sie das gerade jetzt als
Oppositionspolitiker erleben das ist
keine einfache politische Situation im
Gegenteil ich würde sogar
der Regierung anbieten
ähnlich wie Anfang der 2000er Jahre wo
wir eine Arbeitslosigkeit von fünf sechs
Millionen hatten
wo wir diese Agenda 2010 gemacht haben
wo wir konstruktiv mitgemacht haben auch
im Bundesrat würde ich der Regierung
anbieten jetzt das Ding noch mal zu
machen
die letzten zehn Jahre die Dekade das
war eine Dekade mit wirtschaftlichen
Wachstum ja bevor er durch die
Niedrigzinspolitik der Notenbanken und
besonders der EZB die zum Teil muss man
sagen
für skalpolitik gemacht hat
zugegebenermaßen sie soll sich bitte
wieder auf Geldpolitik konzentrieren ja
sie hatten sehr stark im Süden gestützt
indem sie direkt knallhart statt allein
aufgekauft haben damit die Italiener die
Franzosen haben im Moment wieder mehr
Probleme zum Teil beim Anstieg ihre
Schulden ihre Zinsen bedienen können und
nicht so einen Druck haben damit die
sich befreien können aber das eigentlich
Aufgabe der Parlamente Haushaltspolitik
zu machen
und mittlerweile bin ich der Meinung ich
bin jetzt auf ein paar Jahre in der
Politik wir sind jetzt wieder an einem
Zeitpunkt wo wir nicht wie in den
letzten 10 Jahren gutes Wachstum hatten
sondern jetzt stehen wir wieder vor
einer Herausforderung wo wir so was
wieder brauchen wie eine Agenda 2030 wir
müssen den Menschen ein Ziel geben ein
Bild von Deutschland malen wo wir hin
wollen es gibt eine völlige das meine
ich jetzt parteiübergreifen völlige
Verunsicherung sie haben die Inflation
die leider bleiben wird ich glaube
vielen Experten nicht das ist nächstes
Jahr wieder zurück geht auf 2 %, die
Kerninflationsrate vor Ende also die
Inflationsrate ohne Lebensmittel ohne
Energie ohne diese Volatilität liegt bei
über 5 ich gehe davon aus wenn in den
nächsten Jahre zwischen 52% haben ab 25
kommt das Fachkräfte Problem richtig zum
Tragen und dann haben wir noch eine
Situation dass dieser Standort nicht
mehr so wettbewerbsfähig ist und da
braucht es eine Agenda 20 30 und das
erwarte ich auch von einem Bundeskanzler
der sich jetzt in den Bundestag stellt
und den Menschen er muss ja keine Vision
formulieren aber so ein paar Ziele damit
wir nicht mehr so navigieren wie im
Moment nämlich planlos und ziellos okay
und wie zielführend ist dann deswegen
jetzt gerade wie damals zwischen Söder
und Laschet einen kleinen Ringkampf
erleben zwischen Herrn märz und Herrn
wüst das ist nicht zielführend weil die
Herausforderung die ich gerade skizziert
habe so groß sind dass wir uns das nicht
leisten können in der Partei zu streiten
wir brauchen Geschlossenheit und müssen
uns um die Themen der Zukunft kümmern
dann freuen wir uns jetzt Adam Tools
begrüßen zu dürfen
Wirtschaftshistoriker schon vor kurzer
Zeit in dieser Sendung gewesen zu einem
anderen wichtigen Thema Adam Tools
erklärt uns bitte wie und warum die
Inflation so dramatisch auch aus der
Wahrnehmung der Menschen ist die
gefühlte Inflation in Deutschland sagt
man 18 Prozent und nicht diese sechs
also wir haben offensichtlich das Gefühl
dass es noch viel schlimmer ist als die
realen Zahlen oder die statistischen
Kenngrößen jetzt hergeben warum ist das
ein solches Besorgnis aus der sich der
Menschen wenn man das jetzt hochrechnet
geht tatsächlich ja 20% in zwei Jahren
20%
es gibt eigenes Vermögen verloren
wenigstens das also man sollte vor allem
nicht davon ausgehen dass das ein
besonderes deutsches Problem ist also
die Umfrage die diese Schlagzeile
generiert hat zeigte das europaweit die
inflationsperzeption also die
Wahrnehmung der Inflation die
beschriebene Inflation bei 16 Prozent
lag also die Deutschen sind 10% über
diesen europäischen Schnitt und diese
diese Lücke zwischen der wahrgenommenen
Inflation und der gemessenen Inflation
gibt es schon lange gibt es seit dieser
Erhebung existiert die Erhebung entstand
Anfang der 2000er Jahre um die um die
Einführung der Euro abzumessen wo ja
auch so in inflationsschock war wo die
die die Bürger fühlten eine eine
wesentliche Teuerung die über die
gewöhnliche Statistik hinausgänge und
seitdem kracht diese Lücke das
Verhältnis zum Teil größer eine Moment
ist es vielleicht weniger staunlich dass
sie besonders groß ist die Statistiker
kratzen sich mittlerweile seit zwei
Jahrzehnten am Kopf und versuchen das zu
erklären es ist nicht ohne weiteres
einleuchten warum das woran das liegt
man könnte Rundumschlag sagen die
Wirtschaftspublizistik versagt
nicht nur in Deutschland das geht nicht
weil überall Kraft diese Lücke es fehlt
die Vermittlung zwischen der
ökonomischen Statistik der
volkswirtschaftslehrer unter eigenen
Erfahrung aber es gibt auch und sie
haben das so eindringlich beschrieben
offensichtliche
erfahrungsunterschiede zwischen gewisser
Weise dem statistischen Durchschnitt und
den extrem Erfahrung von vielen Menschen
und das kann eine Dauer ein Dauerzustand
der extreme Erfahrung sein oder eben nur
einmal den Job zu merken oh mein Gott
auf einmal kostet dieses Teil das Auto
der den Urlaub bei bei besser gestellt
Menschen 20% mehr also ich erwartet habe
und aus diesem gewisser Weise
statistisch unrepräsentativen
Erfahrungen entsteht dann dieses Bild
man könnte sagen es ist ein
protestschrei also was die Leute in
diesem Moment dokumentieren sozusagen
mir geht's schlecht mir geht's wirklich
schlecht eine richtig schlechte Zahl ist
so um 15% herum die die also die Umfrage
ich habe mir das genau angesehen vor der
Sendung weil mich das auch so baff
gemacht hatte und die Untersuchung der
Untersuchung gehen wirklich ins Detail
und das Framing der Fragen ist sehr
interessant und aufschlussreich die
Leute die Menschen werden wirklich
gefragt was ist ihre Schätzung der
Inflationen die allermeisten Mitbürger
haben keine Ahnung müssen nicht ob Sex
ist oder 8 % wissen aber dass es ihnen
schlecht geht um 15 % ist eine Zahl bei
der man
ich würde so lesen ja Symptome einer
Gefühl eines Unwohlsein einer gefühlten
großen Sorge würden sie auch sagen wir
sollten nicht damit rechnen dass diese
Inflation und zwar nicht nur der erste
Wert sondern tatsächlich die
Kerninflation leider bleiben wird eben
weil die Geldmengen Politik nicht das
einzige Problem nein da bin ich da bin
ich viel optimistischer und Konvent
schneller in dem Sinne dass ich denke
dass tatsächlich wer ist im Grunde gar
nicht nach stricken
volkswirtschaftlichen Kriterien mit
einer Inflation zu tun hatten sondern
mit einem Preisschock der Unterschied
ist dass eine Inflation wirklich eine
selbsttragende allgemeine Bewegung aller
Preise und Löhne ist und gerade das ist
ja nicht eingetreten und gerade deshalb
sind die sozialen Härten ja so extrem
weil viele Menschen überhaupt nicht
mitgetragen worden sind durch die
Inflation ich würde ihn vollkommen Recht
geben dass jede Inflation Herten
beinhaltet es ist immer ein
verteilungskomplex aber wir haben selten
einen so ungleichen verteilungskonflikt
gesehen wie in den letzten 12 Monaten
weil weil
die die gewerkschaftlich getragene
wirklich nicht mitgehalten haben wir
haben eine real Lohn Verlust der
wirklichen Prozent weit hinter der
Inflation zurück das ist von der
makroökonomischen Position wenn sie im
EZB setzen begrüßenswert weil das
Steuerungsproblem einfacher ist gerade
Teil dieser Lohndruck nicht da ist aber
dadurch sind sie noch regelrechte und
registriert zu sozialen Härten ja und
diese diese Durchschnittszahlen deshalb
habe ich mich da auch gerade schon so
ein bisschen drüber dagegen gewehrt die
klaffen ja sehr weit auseinander ich
glaube wenn wir von einer
durchschnittsinflation sprechen und
jetzt auch von dem real lohnverlust von
fast vier Prozent das trifft ja nicht
alle Menschen gleich es gibt Menschen in
diesem Land die auch mal eine Krise auch
mal eine schlechte Phase aushalten
können und wir haben leider leider das
Problem dass wir in Großteil der
Bevölkerung nicht ausgerüstet haben für
krisenhafte Situationen und 40% der
Menschen in Deutschland haben keinen
Erspartes keine Rücklagen 30% fast sagen
eine außergewöhnliche Anschaffung von
1000 € kann ich mir nicht leisten und
das sind die Menschen die ich jetzt sehr
lange begleitet habe und da ist die
Krise fast egal sei es die Pandemie sei
es der preisschopf sei es die
Energiekrise die haben immer sofort das
Gefühl mit dem Rücken zur Wand zu stehen
hilflos zu sein und
das ist ein Gefühl was niemand gerne
möchte ich verstehe das total auch die
wollen handeln die wollen agieren die
wollen Probleme lösen selber autark und
wenn man aber gar keine Rücklagen kein
Erspartes hat dann ist man immer
getrieben ist man immer in der Defensive
das ist so wie das Gefühl habe ich mir
dann immer vorgestellt wenn man die
Karte in den Geldautomaten stellt man
braucht Trinkgeld und es kommt einfach
nichts und wenn das ihr permanenter
Alltag ist und dann sind sie irgendwann
genau dann sind sie irgendwann wund
würde ich sagen und dann sind die Zahlen
die Statistiken so ein bisschen egal was
dann den Druck quasi zum Überkochen
bringen und vielleicht war das jetzt
auch mit Grund für die heizungsaufregung
das halt die der Auslöser dann ein
bisschen egal ist und die Leute dann
eher sagen
was soll ich denn jetzt noch machen ich
ist Haut doch jetzt schon nicht hin und
wenn wir aber alle in einen Topf werfen
und eben nicht gucken welche welchen
Teil der Bevölkerung geht wie ich glaube
dann dann sind wir auch schlechtere
Lösungen sie haben jetzt auch eine Zahl
genannt nämlich eine relative 40% der
Menschen
deshalb können sich eben eine solche
Investition auch nicht leisten und in
dieser Größenordnung nicht leisten es
gibt Menschen denen geht es besser und
auch die haben das Gefühl dass sie vor
unlösbaren Aufgaben stehen freue mich
ganz doll Claudia jeschkowski bei uns zu
begrüßen sie kommt aus dem schönen
Brandenburg arbeitet als
Personalberaterin ist verheiratet hatte
drei Kinder ihr Mann auch
Personalberater sie sind insgesamt 25
Stunden in der Woche beschäftigt und es
geht ihnen eigentlich würde man sagen
ganz gut das ist die klassische
Mittelschicht ich darf verraten dass sie
so auf viereinhalb 5000 € netto im Monat
kommen und trotzdem sagen sie sie müssen
sich einschränken und zwar so dass es
knirscht wo müssen sie sich einschränken
ja also das ist knirscht ist dann halt
an den Dingen die wir in Freizeit Kultur
z.B investieren das heißt wir überlegen
dann einfach aber wie lang ist ein
Urlaub ist ein Urlaub tatsächlich zwei
Wochen lang oder ist ein Urlaub eine
Woche lang da fängt es dann eben schon
an dass man überleben mit zwei Kindern
eine Woche in den genau das ist dann
halt die die Abwägung die man dann
einfach trifft weil wir wollen es als
Familie wir wollen natürlich auch am
Leben
teilhaben und das sind solche Aspekte wo
wir einfach geguckt haben was können wir
verändern was wollen wir verändern oder
was ist dann einfach nur noch in einem
kleineren Rahmen möglich genau dieser
wie sehr schmerzen sie jetzt auch diese
Energiekosten wie sehr müssen Sie auch
bei dem was ihren Kindern sicherlich
Spaß macht sich einschränken also die
Energiekosten sind an sich ähm immer das
Fragezeichen was wird danach daraus
kommen also jetzt ist es klar aber wie
geht das dann in den nächsten Jahren
weiter
und wir haben halt in ferne
wärmedienstleister das heißt man ist
dann eh festgesetzt erstmal auf eine
sehr lange Zeit und ähm kann man jetzt
aber in anderer Hinsicht
genau und
das heißt natürlich andere Dinge fallen
dann oder werden anders betrachtet ne
also wir haben vor drei Jahren Anfrage
zum Beispiel für eine was vorhin um
Reparatur ging auch gestellt für
Dachfenster Reparatur wir haben das
Angebot dieses Jahr wieder erneuert wir
haben dreifach höheren Preis für das
gleiche Material für die gleiche
Dienstleistung und das sind dann die
Dinge wo wir sagen okay wir überlegen
wie dringlich ist es tatsächlich den
Invest jetzt gerade zu gehen weil wir
haben eine Jahresplanung wir haben eine
Idee wir haben in Schulanfang der
ansteht also wo guckst Du einfach hin
und wegst ab was Du tatsächlich hier
jetzt günstig ja und wo müssen Sie mit
den Kindern einschränken das haben sie
erwähnt müssen Sie da auch wirklich
überlegen ob es in den Tierpark geht für
alle vier obs in den es geht dann halt
nicht in der Häufigkeit dorthin weil
natürlich die Eintrittspreise sich
verändert haben und es ist natürlich
auch logisch und es soll auch so sein
dass jeder das bekommt was er auch an
Kosten hat aber das ist halt dann wo man
dahin gucken sagt ja
okay
ich sie haben erzählt dass sie auch bei
ihrer Altersvorsorge sparen und das
finde ich besonders bedenklich weil es
einem Jahr selbst in doppelter
Hinsichten blödes Gefühl gibt
wie viel Geld sparen Sie da jetzt im
Monat also es sind über
150 Euro die ein angehalten worden sind
letztendlich pro Monat das ist
sicherlich für manche unfassbar dass das
nicht drin ist aber das ist einfach
jetzt im Moment so dass ich diese Sachen
erstmal angehalten habe und wenn sie
dann in diese Zukunft schauen wie viele
Sorgen machen sie sich
na schon dahingehend dass das was man
sich selber so fürs Leben vorstellt und
was man sich wünscht als Familie und
auch für Kinder
vielleicht schwieriger wird zu
realisieren und das Wünsche erstmal
ausgebremst werden und das finde ich
einfach
gerade mit dem Blick auch was die Runde
sagt wichtig dass man guckt wie man
diesen Start und das was da in Zukunft
wieder wachsen soll in Bewegung kriegt
und die Menschen auch wieder motiviert
und ihnen nicht das Gefühl gibt dass sie
da eigentlich überall scheitern genau
sie arbeiten jetzt 25 Stunden wie sehr
verändert sich auch ihre Arbeit haben
Sie das Gefühl bietet Ihnen Ihr
Arbeitgeber auch mal an ein bisschen
mehr zu bezahlen gibt es diese
Diskussionen dass sie auch einen höheren
Lohn verlangen für sich oder
das gibt es natürlich immer in
Jahresplanungen und dann ist immer die
Frage ist das sozusagen budgetiert mit
dabei und im letzten Jahr hatte ich ja
noch eine andere Situation aber ich noch
ein Elternteilzeit deswegen ist das
erstmal eine Runde pausiert aber
natürlich wäre ich das auch tun für mich
weil die Löhne nicht sich automatisch
anpassen nur wenn es irgendwo eine
Prämie für einen Arbeitgeber gibt ne
also
so und natürlich sind sie auch ja so
schlau auch in den Intentionen des
Arbeitgebers zu denken und zu sagen für
alle steigen gerade die Kosten und das
was da irgendwie angemessen ist muss
natürlich jeder am Ende irgendwie auch
bekommen oder Zahlen AFD wollte ich sie
noch Fragen bundesweit ist die Partei
jetzt bei 18 Prozent sie leben im Norden
Berlins in Panketal das ist schon
Brandenburg aber im Berliner Speckgürtel
insgesamt im Osten die AFD eben bei 28
%. wie sehr glauben Sie dass diese
Unsicherheit die wir hier besprochen
haben dieses da kommen jetzt drei Krisen
übereinander und eigentlich wissen wir
nicht was wir zuerst machen sollen dass
das ein Grund ist für das Erstarken der
Partei oder glauben Sie dass es einen
anderen Grund hat also ich denke einfach
dass bei vielen Entscheidungen die
getroffen worden sind zu wenig
Transparenz ist politischen Entscheidung
ja genau zum Beispiel
wie wie diese Diskussion die jetzt über
Wärmepumpen also der Weg dorthin das ist
für manche zu zu langatmig sie steigen
dann einfach aus weil das kommt keiner
dann mit also die einfachere Sprache
finden und versuchen auch plausibel
Dinge zu erklären und auch Dinge zu
finden die ich halt in dem laufenden
Jahr Menschen zurückgeben kann ohne dass
man lange Instanzen gehen darf und auch
gucken sollte wenn wir jetzt eine Idee
haben wie in 49 € Ticket und so weiter
wie gut funktioniert das treffe ich mit
meiner Entscheidung tatsächlich den Kern
die Bedürftigen ja oder ähm passiert da
wieder nur was hinten rum also werden
vorhin auch das Gespräch Benzinpreise
Mehrwertsteuer und so weiter eine Zeit
lang ist tatsächlich der Effekt
eingetreten die man sich erhofft hat ja
weil auch ein Geschäftsführer mit einem
Dienstwagen
hat davon profitiert also man muss halt
immer gucken mache ich nicht sehr genau
und wie soll es funktionieren für die
Menschen und dann denke ich ist es gut
ist ihn einfach zu sagen
genau und dann ist glaube ich auch das
ähm auf Schlachtrufe zu reagieren er
dann zwei dran ich
auf die Schlachtrufe von anderen
Parteien
klasse dass wir sie heute bei uns haben
sie haben sich gewünscht dass wir hier
so fokussiert sprechen sonst hätten wir
sie auch mit in die Runde genommen in
natürlich ist ihr Wunsch uns Befehle es
ist toll dass wir sie heute hier hatten
danke schön alles Liebe für sie und wir
sind jetzt wieder in der Runde und
fragen uns natürlich Herr Kühnert wie
kann man auch in dieser Gruppe in
unserer Gesellschaft Angst nehmen und
Sorge nehmen
naja dass diese Welt eine ziemlich
turbulente im Moment ist das wird auch
jeder andere Bundesregierung nicht so
einfach wieder vom Kopf auf die Füße
stellen können wir sind einfach in der
Situation in der ganz viele Umbrüche
passieren Globalisierung und
Digitalisierung wirken sich aus der
Krieg die Energiekrise und anderes mehr
die Zeit die wir verschlafen haben und
nicht mehr reinholen können als
Gesellschaft beim Klimaschutz weshalb
wir nicht jeden Schritt in der
Geschwindigkeit langsam hintereinander
machen können erst die wärmeplanung und
dann alle Haushalte einzeln abklappern
wie das in einer idealen Welt der Fall
wäre also es wird ein bisschen ruckelig
in den nächsten Jahren immer mal wieder
sein unsere Aufgabe ist dafür ja unsere
Aufgabe ist ja dafür zu sorgen dass das
nicht einfach pauschal bei allen
gleichermaßen Durchschnitt denn jeder
nicht jeder kann das gleich gut
abfedern deswegen hat diese Koalition ja
auch von Anfang an einen Schwerpunkt
gesetzt noch bevor das mit Krieg und
Inflation und einem so durch die Decke
gegangen ist z.B mit der Entscheidung
für die mindestlohnerhöhung auf 12 Euro
das ist für uns sagt jetzt die
Kommission wieder am Montag muss der
Mindestlohn hochgehen wir sind bei
diesem Gedanken die Menschen trifft es
natürlich viel mehr die weniger in im
Portemonnaie haben weil sie eben einen
Buße hatten in der letzten Zeit das wird
er das muss er nach der Art wie wieder
Mindestlohn gestrickt ist weil er hat
sich zu orientieren an der allgemeinen
Lohnentwicklung und da die hochgeht wenn
auch gar nicht so sehr wie manche das
Denken wird auch der Mindestlohn weiter
hochgehen und zwar trotzdem jetzt einmal
dieser politische Schritt auf 12 €
wichtig eine lohnverbesserung für 6
Millionen Menschen weil das natürlich
gerade diejenigen sind von den Frau
Friedrich beispielsweise vorhin
gesprochen hat bei denen wirklich schon
alles
ausgereizt gewesen ist in der
Vergangenheit die müssen im Mittelpunkt
stehen für die muss gute Beschäftigung
da sein wir kommen die Zeit eines
arbeitnehmer-marktes das heißt immer
häufiger suchen sich die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer die
Unternehmen aus was eine gute
Verhandlungsposition ist wir sehen es an
dem Zuwachs der Gewerkschaften die die
Tarifverträge in diesem ersten Halbjahr
behandelt haben wer die im Bereich des
öffentlichen Dienstes oder der Post und
andere mehr haben irrsinnige Mitglieder
Zuwächse das heißt die Beschäftigten in
Deutschland erkennen ihre
Verhandlungsmacht auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
wieder ich will uns kein schlanken Fuß
machen und sagen die Politik hat gar
keine Aufgabe wir haben viele Sachen
abzufedern gerade im Bereich der
Energiewende und andere mehr aber es ist
eben schon Kernaufgabe unserer immer
noch gut funktionierenden
Volkswirtschaft Beschäftigte angemessen
zu beteiligen und letztes Jahr waren
Leute unterwegs und haben von der Lohn
Preisspirale gesprochen spricht die
haben versucht den Beschäftigten in
Deutschland wegen angeblich zu hoher
Lohnforderung noch die Schuld für die
Inflation in die Schuhe zu stecken das
Gegenteil ist der Fall das heißt wir
versuchen eine Politik zu machen wie zum
Beispiel Tarifbindung Stärke wir werden
dieses Jahr ein Tarif Treue gesetzt
durchsetzen damit staatliches Geld
Steuer Geld der Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler nicht mehr für Lohndumping
eingesetzt wird sondern nur an solche
Unternehmen im öffentlichen Auftrag geht
die zu Tarifbedingungen die Arbeit auch
ausführen lassen das sind reale
politische Maßnahmen mit denen wir es
schaffen die Verhandlungsmacht und Basis
von Beschäftigten zu verbessern das sind
wichtiger Punkt sie haben Helene Mann
gesagt dass diese Bundesregierung keinen
wirtschaftlichen Sachverstand hat haben
Sie Christian Lindner damit einbezogen
da ist ja noch ein Korrektiv zumindest
in dieser Bundesregierung aber was mich
wundert ist wenn jetzt so ein Fall sehen
die gerade ich sag mal erstmal möchte
ich ja in einem Land leben wo zwei
arbeiten
sich ja viel eigene Wende leisten können
ein Auto in Urlaub und es mal auf den
Punkt zu bringen das muss in einem Land
wo die soziale Marktwirtschaft gilt
möglich sein und wieder möglich sein und
der zweite Punkt ist der Stichwort
Inflation wir haben über die Geldpolitik
gesprochen dann haben wir immer noch
Friktionen im Bereich des Angebots also
Lieferengpässe und so weiter das steigt
auch aber jetzt deshalb steigt auch die
Inflation weil die Nachfrage steigt aber
die das Angebot kommt nicht nach jetzt
kommt der dritte Punkt das ist die
Verschuldungspolitik nicht nur dieser
Bundesregierung sondern auch insgesamt
weil wenn sie verschulden und das Geld
geht in den Kreislauf geht auch wieder
die Inflation
nein das was die Regierung falsch macht
und darüber muss man echt mal
konzentriert reden
ob wir ich sag mal bei allen
hilfsinstrumenten haben wir immer alle
bedacht also als es um die um die
Tankstelle ging um den Tankrabatt alle
300 Euro energiepauschale alle die
gaspreisbremse alle 9 Euro
Kinderzuschlag diesen neuen und unsere
alle das heißt mit anderen Worten wenn
wir so weiter unnötig das war völlig
unnötig wenn wir es nicht schaffen in
diesem Lande das ist wirklich um diese
40 %. ich meine um die Menschen 20% der
Menschen arbeiten für zweieinhalb
Tausend Euro brutto im Monat wenn wir
uns nicht auf die konzentrieren sondern
mit der Gießkanne weitermachen dann
werden wir weiter jedes Jahr 100
Milliarden Schulden machen den Inflation
jetzt steigen und wir kriegen eben nicht
dieses Ziel das war das Land sie wissen
doch ganz genau es gibt
waren 16 Jahre in der Regierung es gibt
kein Instrument bislang in Deutschland
um quasi auf einen Knopf zu drücken und
zu sagen zahle allen mit einem
monatlichen Einkommen bis hier und
weiterhin so und so viel Geld aus wenn
es die Möglichkeit gegeben hätte hätten
wir das ja gemacht der Schmerz war ja
überall öffentlich zu vernehmen dass wir
die energiepreispauschale auch sehr gut
verdienen ausgezahlt haben die sie ja
dann übrigens versteuern mussten hätten
wir die passgenaue Einzelfalllösung
gemacht wobei jedem noch mal die genauen
Lebensverhältnisse angeguckt wird die
Leute hätten Pflaumen Pfingsten noch
keine energiepreispauschale gehabt das
kann doch auch nicht die Antwort am Ende
sein dann ist es doch richtiger erstmal
zu handeln um die akute Not von den
Leuten die nicht auf der hohen Kante
haben die auch nicht erstmal warten
können ist die Regierung sich ausgekickt
hat die zu beheben und dann gemeinsam
z.B politisch darüber zu sprechen wie
man ein anderer Stelle
rückholende Verteilungsgerechtigkeit
wieder herstellen kann wo starke
Schultern mehr tragen als schwächere das
wäre ja richtig gibt verschiedene
Konzepte sie können es ganz einfach
machen Sie nehmen einfach die
Steuererklärung eines jeden und sagen
jemand der 120.000 € oder was beim
doppelverdienst was weiß ich 200000
verdient oder was auch immer ist raus
und alle anderen da drunter werden
entlastet kannst auch drei Stufen machen
ganz einfach aber diese Milliarden die
sie raus ballern das stimuliert wieder
die Inflation und nächstes Jahr sitzen
wir wieder hier ist die Argumentation
nicht nur von Herrn Linnemann sondern
auch von Christian Lindner zu sagen wir
müssen nicht uns nur um die Konjunktur
sorgen sondern wir müssen uns auch darum
sorgen dass die Menschen genau dieses
Gefühl haben dass zu viel Geld in
gleichen Teilen für alle ausgegeben
worden ich meine das mag politisch ein
Politikum sein aber macht ökonomisch
ist es einfach falsch also im Moment ist
die fiskalpolitische Einstellung der
Bundesregierung wie auch im gesamten
restlichen Europa haben wir auch in
Amerika Inflation negativ das heißt also
man man schließt die die die Defizit
Lücken die Defizite sind noch da die
Schulden steigen aber im Verhältnis zum
Vorjahr ist die das ist definitiv
kleiner das heißt der netto-effekt für
die Inflation ist negativ die Politik
drückt gegen die Inflation im Moment man
kann das Argument machen dass man noch
stärker in diese Richtung schieben
sollte aber die Schule also die Defizite
per se sind im Moment keine Inflation
Treiber man kann lange längerfristig
über Nachhaltigkeit und all das
diskutiert aber das ist eine andere
Frage die Inflation zu
instrumentalisieren um jetzt gegen
Schuldenpolitik zu machen ist ist
einfach auch potenistisch das ist
opportunistisch und das sollte man nicht
tun wir müssen unbedingt noch über
gierflation reden weil es ist so
wahnsinnig interessant zu verstehen
Wallstreet diesen Kinofilm erinnern Sie
Gordon Gecko sagt den berühmten Satz das
Gier gut ist das denken sich auch
einzelne Unternehmen und sorgen dafür
dass die Preise steigen und zwar einfach
so
es ist der weiße Elefant im Raum
die gierflation
Unternehmen nutzen die Inflation um
Profite zu maximieren
Preissteigerungen also die nicht
aufgestiegenen Rohstoff und
Energiepreisen basieren vor allem bei
Fernwärme und Gasanbietern ruft das
jetzt das Bundeskartellamt auf den Plan
wir haben jetzt erstmal gegen eine
zweistellige Zahl an Unternehmen an
Gasversorgern ein Verfahren eingeleitet
und überprüfen ob diese Unternehmen
möglicherweise die Preise zu Unrecht
erhöht haben aber auch andere Branchen
langen zu laut EZB sind die Hälfte der
Preissteigerungen Profitmaximierung
die Hälfte der Steigerungen sind
profitmaximierungen also da sind Firmen
Versorger mit der Welle geschwommen weil
man Hersteller gerade die Preise erhöht
sich klar dann kann sie ein bisschen
jemand anders Schuld geben also es gibt
es gibt Unternehmen es gibt ich würde
das Begriff bierflation können wir
vielleicht definieren ob das der
richtige Wort ist aber ist es so dass
Unternehmen die Gelegenheit genutzt hat
die Preise zu erhöhen ja warum ist es
das so wenn alle Preise steigen ist es
viel leichter Preise zu erhöhen dass man
die Preise nicht steigen das ist erstmal
ein rationales Verhalten der Unternehmen
oder will jetzt noch nicht sagen jetzt
hier ist
beispielrechnet es ist vor allem im
Bereich Landwirtschaft und im Bereich
Bauindustrie
also es kann Handwerker hat den Preis
erhöht ja ich könnte aber auch sagen ja
ich könnte aber auch sagen der Handwerk
hat höhere Kosten Handwerk hat er auch
höhere Lebenshaltungskosten mal seinen
Gewinn ist ja sein Einkommen also wie er
Kühnert sagt die mit die Mitarbeiter die
Arbeiter sollen auf die Straße geht
demonstrieren sollen mit in die
Gewerkschaften gehen soll für höhere
Einkommen demonstrieren genauso hat der
Handwerker ein Interesse an eigenes
Einkommens erhöhen also kann man doch
jetzt nicht in den Handwerker sagen also
ist ihr flation er verteidigt einfach
nur gut seine Einkommen
natürlich gibt es große Unternehmen die
ist ausgenutzt haben
wieso geht das überhaupt mal ausnutzen
das wäre meine Frage das ist genau das
ist die Frage wie lange guckt man da
eigentlich zu und haben wir tatsächlich
nur das kleine karteller
also erstmal ist es so normalerweise
wäre es gar nicht möglich weil es geht
nur dann möglich wenn zu hohen Nachfrage
da ist und warum haben wir zu viel
Nachfrage wir haben zu viel Nachfrage
weil wir ein Zuckerschock in der
Wirtschaft hatten wie Sie wenn Sie zu
viel Zucker essen dann haben Sie auch im
Blut sogar Schock und sind für sie
aufgekratzt und das ist in der
Wirtschaft warum wir haben ja
corona-zeit haben wir direkt das Geld in
die Venen der Wirtschaft gepumpt die
Staaten haben Geld ausgezahlt
Kurzarbeiter Geld anderes und die
Notenbanken haben was direkt finanziert
das war quasi direkte gedruckt ja das
war konkret gedruckt ne haben sie nicht
wundern wenn plötzliche Nachfrage damals
erstmal Versicherungsleistungen
es geht doch keiner die US Checks nehmen
was weiß wir haben eine Reaktion gehabt
wo ganz viel Geld die Wirtschaft kam was
erstmal gar nicht ausgegeben werden
konnte weil Leute zu Hause saßen konnte
gar nicht ausgeben und ich Lieferketten
waren gestört darum kann man sich nicht
wundern wenn Inflation kam und deshalb
in so einem Umfeld kann man das
ausnutzen jetzt geht es aber zurück wenn
sich die Geldmengen anschauen die
Geldmengen real schrumpfen bereits in
USA sie fangen an in Europa zu
schrumpfen die Kreditvergabe geht zurück
das heißt ihr könnt durchaus das
Szenario machen dass wir leider Gottes
in der Tat in Europa aber auch USA und
auch in China in der Rezession kommen
und dann sowieso Schluss mit dem
musikmarschen dann sinken die Maßen
wieder also das ist für mich ein
temporäres für Erwin wo ich sage ja wohl
da gab es mittelt
sofort sagen wir alle besteuern ganz
kurz dann sage ich ja das Problem an der
ganzen Sache ist nur dann müssen sie
definieren
mein Beitrag Was ist zu viel
definieren was ist zu viel also sie
müssten sie auch mal sagen was ist denn
zu wenig muss ich das unter Umständen zu
wenig gewiss auch bezahlen ich kann
schwieriges Thema den Weg würde ich gar
nicht gehen der Markt dann wird der
Markus in der Tat lösen und wir können
das lösen dann müssen wir einfach
hingehen als Konsequenzen auf dieses
Produkt
und als Bürger nur sagen hier ermittelt
zum Glück der Chef des Kartellamtes von
Deutschland
heute noch bei den Stromversorgern also
nicht nur konzentrieren wir uns mal auf
die energieversorge die haben diese
Situation offensichtlich ausgenutzt und
der geht es der TuS ja nicht nur um das
Geld der Kunden sondern es geht ja dazu
eben auch noch um Starts Milliarden wenn
man so will also auch noch mal doppelt
das Geld das Steuerzahlers das ist doch
eigentlich kriminell wir haben eine
Verachtfachung der Preise gehabt am
Anfang dieser Abschlagszahlungen dann
kam die Informationen nach vier Monaten
dass das Kartellamt jetzt mal prüfen
könnte und dann haben die langsam
angefangen diese
abschlagshöhen zu minimieren es wurden
die auf Null gesetzt die waren vorher
die Verachtfachung in unser auf Null
gesetzt und jetzt sind sie irgendwie
eine Verdreifachung des vorherigen
Betrages so Frage ganz kurz darf man
sich als Bürger darüber aufregen
sollte man sich bestimmt ja ich denke
auch wenn man jetzt die kausale
Erklärung die ich durchaus plausibel
finde dass das die Gier im Grunde nicht
der Grund ist sondern die Gelegenheit
die Gelegenheit auf der anderen Seite
und der Druck nämlich Kosten zukünftige
Kosten Erhöhung aber ein riesiges Drama
dahinter aber was wenn es Absprachen gab
wenn es recht brüchig ist dann ist es
natürlich ein Skandal und und angesichts
der gegebenen Armut und Ungleichheit
sind diese opportunistischen
gelegenheitsstrategien der Film
offensichtlich
ein Brennstoff ich weiß nicht hätte
dieser Regierung etwas einfallen können
das zu beheben es gab ein gutes Modell
in Spanien die haben eine Art Preis
Beobachtung gemacht glaube ich
hätte es frühere Möglichkeiten gegeben
den Leuten ja auch die Angst zu nehmen
jetzt einen verachtfachten Preis zahlen
zu müssen auf zwei Seiten man hätte man
hätte zu einer pauschalen
Preisregulierung kommen können und man
hätte auf der anderen Seite bei den
Einkommen unmittelbaren schnell
nachhelfen können und ich denke da wäre
eine Beschleunigung bestimmt zur
Entschädigung hätte eine Beschleunigung
zur Entspannung beigetragen ich meine
das ist das ist ein zentrales Problem
und wir haben das Tempo dieser Bewegung
und seine Brisanz verschlafen muss man
sagen der also die wirtschaftspolitische
Elite die da die Entscheidung trifft war
zu spät war zu spät mit ihren Reaktionen
auf diese dreifachkrise im Grunde
genommen und und vor allem weil das zu
uns zur Verfügung stehende Instrument
bei der Zinspolitik ja dann sehr wenig
hilft das heißt es ist nicht so dass man
die anderen Mittel Weg verschlafen hat
und dann eigentlich ein schlagende ein
starkes und Instrument hat denn im
Grunde kann man davon ausgehen dass die
Zinspolitik nicht helfen wird umso mehr
Grund deshalb schneller zu diesen
anderen Mitteln zu greifen und danach
wollte ich sie fragen es gab in
Frankreich Bruno leer der
Wirtschaftsminister hat die Initiative
ergriffen die Grundnahrungsmittel über
einen Quart zu subventionieren zu
stützen dafür zu sorgen dass die
Menschen da eben nicht eine
70-prozentige Steigerung haben haben sie
sowas vermisst hier in Deutschland
überhaupt das thematisieren dessen
nochmal tatsächlich sehr lange gewundert
dass die Preissteigerung bei den
Lebensmitteln in Deutschland so ein
bisschen unter dem Radar geblieben sind
und ich glaube das hat einfach mit
Lebenswelt zu tun wenn Menschen die gut
verdienen die sagen einmal ach mann wenn
wir zum Rewe gehen oder in einen anderen
Supermarkt ganz schön teuer geworden da
riecht man sich ein bisschen drüber auf
und ich glaube weil die Lebenswelt derer
die wenig Geld haben sich sehr weit
entfernt hat weil man da wenig man hat
auch die Menschen in den ökonomischen
Instituten und auch in der Politik
vielleicht dann nicht so viel Kontakt
haben ist lange diese dieses Ausmaß der
Krise ist glaube ich nicht in dem Drama
wahrgenommen worden ich meine wir haben
zwei Millionen Menschen bei den Tafeln
das ist auch mit den geflüchteten aus
der Ukraine zu tun aber hat auch damit
zu tun dass diese Lebensmittel wirklich
brutalst reinschlagen und ich finde sie
haben gerade sehr gut was beschrieben
der Handwerker nimmt sich sein Stück vom
Kuchen wir haben auch gesehen die
Dax-Unternehmen haben es geschafft im
letzten Jahr sich ihr Stück vom Kuchen
zu nehmen da wird die Umsätze und die
Gewinne weitestgehend gut gelaufen
Inseln nimmt sich ein Stück vom Kuchen
und sehr viele Menschen gerade eben ich
will ja nicht so weit drauf rumreiten
aber das unter die untere das untere
Drittel haben eben das Gefühl sie kommen
nicht an ihr Stück vom Kuchen und die
sehen ja das ist ja jetzt auch nicht nur
die letzten zwei drei Jahre sondern wir
sehen ja über einen breiten Zeitraum das
bei dieser Gruppe die Wohlstandsgewinne
nicht angekommen sind das über lange
lange Jahre eben bei denen das was wir
an volkswirtschaftlichen Zuwachs haben
nicht angekommen ist und die sagen noch
mal Entschuldigung an die Politik
Stichwort Preiskontrolle in eben
inflationsstarken Zeiten sie markieren
die Kerninflation und sagen eigentlich
ist es noch viel schlimmer es wird nicht
nur von acht auf sieben auf sechs und
immer weiter runter gehen sondern wir
haben eine kernimation die liegt bei 5
und wird wahrscheinlich bei 54% bleiben
was wirklich dramatisch ist weil
Menschen dann über einen längeren
Zeitraum Werte verlieren Vermögen
verlieren das ist einfach weg so wird
man sich das ist die Gegenfrage wird man
sich dieses diese höheren Preise die die
Unternehmen machen irgendwann wieder
zurückholen wann gehen die Preise von
den Unternehmen wieder zurück oder ist
es die nächste Illusion
also wie gesagt ich habe Meinung dass
das länger dauert als andere zum
Beispiel tust das teile ich nicht das
ist aber eine Meinung zum zweiten muss
man natürlich immer aufpassen in dem
Moment wo die Politik sagt ich
subventioniere beispielsweise beim Strom
wo wir sagen 80 Prozent des
Jahresverbrauchs zahlt der Staat bis 40
Cent dann muss natürlich das Kartell
Arbeiten
sofort aufpassen und sofort wissen oh oh
oh da könnte es sein dass es da
Möglichkeiten gibt Spielräume für die
Unternehmen zu nutzen das würde ich aber
nicht in der Breite sehen im Gegenteil
wir sehen ja im Moment dass es so ist
ist die großen sehen die
flächendeckenend sagen ich investiere
stärker im Ausland zum Teil gar nicht
mehr in Deutschland oder ich werde
direkt so funktioniert wie Intel
und die kleinen der Mittelstand die
Mittelschicht die sterben ganz leise
kriegen sie nicht mehr mit Helen und das
hängt damit zusammen und das hängt damit
zusammen dass dieses dass dieses Land
seit 20 30 40 Jahren eigentlich keine
grundlegende Einkommensteuer gemacht hat
wir haben vor 30 40 Jahren da musste man
das fünf Jahren sogar Millionäre zu
besteuern da mussten sie das 15 bis 20
fache eines durchschnittlichen Lohnes
verdienen um den Spitzensteuersatz zu
sein heute reicht das 1,3fach raus das
heißt die kompletten bis zumindestlohn
der muss ja auch Steuern bezahlen in
drei Stunden im Bereich sogar 100 so
viel bis hin zu Leuten Facharbeitern die
60 70.000 verdienen die werden
überproportional ich würde wirklich
sagen seit Jahrzehnten belastet und hier
eine grundlegende Steuerreform anzulegen
wäre extrem wichtig weil diese dieser
Teil der Gesellschaft der der fühlt sich
vergessen und wenn der da im Fernsehen
sieht 10 Milliarden kriegen die mit
in der Gesellschaft dürfen wir uns
raufen ganz kurz weil es so schön ist
aber weil es auch richtig ist ich kaufe
Ihnen das überhaupt nicht ab und ich
finde wirklich nach den Entscheidungen
die sie mit getroffen haben und wie sie
sich verhalten haben mit der Union im
Deutschen Bundestag können Sie sich
diese Krokodilstränen sparen sie können
da hier nicht ein großes Lied für die
Leute mit den kleinen Einkommen und den
Mittelstand singen und dabei
verschweigen dass sie als wir in die
Frage nach 12 € Mindestlohn im Bundestag
gestellt haben sich heldenhaft enthalten
haben sie hätten die Möglichkeit gehabt
für 6 Millionen Menschen die wirklich
hart arbeiten gehen wie was immer alle
betonen und dafür sehr wenig nach Hause
bringen für die was zu machen sie haben
sich dem aber verweigert stattdessen
stellen sie irgendwo oder ganz weit oben
in weiter ferner Zukunft eine
Steuerreform ins Schaufenster die jetzt
im Moment gar niemanden was bringt das
ist verlogen so und ich finde da müssen
die Tarifarbeit ist die Arbeit der Tarif
Partner die machen das sowohl in den
Mindestlöhnen und so weiter aber jetzt
kommt das war vor 20 Jahren die
Argumentation haben sie geschaffen mit
der Einführung des Bürgergeldes in
Deutschland die Menschen der niedrige
Mann Entschuldigung natürlich war der
vorher da aber du musst heute meiner
Familie mit zwei Kindern musst du 18 19
Euro Mindestlohn haben um davon zu leben
die Leute aber drei Kinder doch keine
Auswirkungen darauf dass die
Briefzustellerin die ich begleitet habe
die 12,3 Lohn verdient
genau
die musst unterstellen sie ja den
Menschen die für wenig Geld arbeiten
dass die immer im Kopf haben oh ich hör
auf zu arbeiten und Kassier dann das
Bürgergeld das ist überhaupt nicht ich
glaube gerade die Ursachen das Problem
Tarifvertrag hat
ganz kurz den Anschlusspunkt zu finden
ehrlich gesagt weil es interessant weil
ich einfach beobachtet das und sagt mir
das eigentlich nicht ist ein bisschen
wenn ich darf das ist eigentlich
symptomatisch für das was schief läuft
bei uns im Land weil das war eine
wichtige Diskussionen mindestens und Sie
haben recht das soll nicht der startet
was weiß ich sie haben Vorgespräch das
ist zu wenig sie haben Rechtes zu tief
ganz ehrlich die Lösung dieser Frage
löst unsere Probleme in Deutschland
überhaupt nicht die sind so
fundamentalen grundlegend
sie haben gesagt warum haben wir
diskutiert erstmal warum subventioniere
ich Nahrungsmittelpreise ich habe vorhin
schon mal gesagt wir können uns nicht in
Wohlstand zu funktionieren was er machen
müssen ist wir müssen dass die haben für
sorgen dass die Menschen alle in die
gerade tiefen mehr Geld in der Tasche
haben und
nun leben können
sehr wichtig ich habe nicht drin Moment
richtig die Diskussion ist ganz wichtig
weil die Frage ist wie erreichen wir das
denn und haben sie gesagt wir müssen
irgendwo stand Teil haben da bin ich mit
einer Meinung und dann sage ich aber wir
sind eine Illusion des Wohlstandes
nochmal ich habe es vorhin schon erklärt
wir haben viel mehr Menschen eine
Beschäftigung die Anzahl Menschen in
Deutschland arbeitet darf ich war noch
nie so hoch
aber und darauf habe ich die Wünsche
auch gewachsen Vergangenheit
Arbeitsstunden sind
nicht da wir müssen die Produktivität
hochbekommen und das müssen wir ins Land
investieren wir müssen die Leute wir
müssen die alle befähigen mehr zu
erwirtschaften und da können wir es auch
besser versetzen
profitiert davon wenn die Wirtschaft
gesamter fordert und dann geht's ganz
gut das Problem wenn du jetzt einfach
anfangen dann kommen wir zu Ihrem
Szenario das finde ich eigentlich
ich habe doch nicht gegen gehören
Gehälter plädiert ich sage nur die
Gehälter für Millionen Menschen sind sie
über Jahre nicht Realität gewesen das
ist doch ein theoretisch nein
das ist der Realität diese Leute keine
Tarif bitte ihren Branchen und ja keine
höheren Löhne bekommen bis der
mindestens eingeführt wurde aber das ist
doch immer aussprechen wir haben sehr
lange schon aber es bringt mich auch
muss ich sagen
dass ich nicht mit den Grundsätzen von
Wirtschaft beschäftigen wollen nur damit
ganz klingen aber ich muss es Ihnen
leider sagen da ist ein Kern dran weil
nur das Gehalt zu erhöhen löst
perspektivisch das Problem nicht weil
das würde mich dazu führen wenn die
Produktivität nicht steigt das dann
jetzt mache
ganz konkreten es gibt Millionen
Menschen die Minijob haben und ein
Hauptjob die Arbeiten keine Stunde
länger weil sie sagen 60% Abgaben und
Steuern sind weg dann nehme ich lieber
ein Mindestlohn und damit erreichen wir
die Produktivitätssteigerung die
Anschluss die Sie ansprechen nicht es
wäre doch viel interessanter wenn
derjenige im Hauptjob noch eine Stunde
arbeitet weil dort die Produktivität
entsteht mein Vorschlag 40 Stunden
Deckeln Vollzeit und jeder der eine
Überstunde macht macht das steuerfrei
dass er weiß wenn ich jetzt eine Stunde
mehr arbeite habe ich das auch netto
Abgaben müssen bezahlt werden im
Portemonnaie dann lohnt sich auch wieder
Leistung in Deutschland im Moment haben
die Leute einfach egal wie viel ich
arbeite 50 60% sind weg das werden
konkreter
Arbeitnehmern ich vorhin das habe ich
mir gemerkt ja nach den Unternehmen
gefragt die sich trauen in einer
dreifachkrise höhere Preise zu verlangen
und es ein Kartellamt braucht um sie
daran zu erinnern dass wenn es
Preisabsprachen gegeben hat und ihre
reguläre Preiserhöhungen dass sie dann
bestraft werden in welcher Größenordnung
wird ein solches Unternehmen bestraft
würde mich jetzt noch interessieren und
wird es zu schaffen sein durch unsere
Kartellbehörde sie wissen besser als ich
wie gut die besetzt sind
diesen ganzen Fällen nachzugehen wenn es
irreguläre Preisabsprachen gab also ich
würde schon den Kartell am zutrauen den
nachzugehen die große Straßen sind
glaube Vergangenheit Millionen Strafen
hundert Millionen Strafen wenn sie an
bestimmte Branche denken wo sowas gab es
gibt es schon ähm ihr müsst dann Schritt
weiter gehen du bist eigentlich sagen
wir haben ja schon Konsolidierung das
nennt man Konzentration in dem Branchen
ja schon seit Jahren uns geht ja nicht
nur in Deutschland auch in USA gerade
das heißt es ein grundlegendes Problem
wo wir eigentlich dass sie Fragen
stellen müssen sind daneben zu groß
geworden kann man auch mal diskutieren
aber im Prinzip wenn es einen Verstoß
gab würde ich sagen jawohl das kartellam
wird das finden und dann gibt es heftige
Strafen weil es sind gestrafen da gibt
es teilweise Hunderte von Millionen die
lassen wurden kommen Sie darauf an wie
groß ist daneben ist und wie groß wer
damit erwirtschaftete unberechtigte
Gewinne ist und darüber haben wir auch
schon geredet dann ist ja diese Idee der
übergewinnsteuer in Zeiten der Gaskrise
im Raum gewesen für die besonderen
zusätzlichen Gewinne sozusagen von vor
allen Dingen Gasanbietern was man sich
auf der anderen Seite jetzt natürlich
auch noch mal überlegen könnte was die
Wirtschaft eigentlich verändern kann und
muss Erdem tust in Bezug auf die
Rezession in der wir uns befinden das
möchten wir gerne noch schaffen und
sagen und fragen wenn wir wenn in
Deutschland tatsächlich Abstieg zu
befürchten ist aus all den genannten
Gründen und wir jetzt in so einer
Subventionitis sind um bestimmte
Technologien zu halten aber eigentlich
eine technische Rezession schon da ist
und vielleicht ein Abstieg droht was hat
die Wirtschaft dann eigentlich falsch
gemacht und was müsste sie anders tun
ich weiß nicht ob ich diese Einschätzung
Teile und diese Panik mache um diese
Vorstellung ist eines Abstieges das
entspricht ja einfach den Tatsachen
nicht also selbst eine Inflation
produziert ja an sich kein Verlust für
die Wirtschaft als Ganzes ist ein
unverteilungsprozess der Teil der
hässlich und ein absolut hässlicher und
sehr ungleich verteilter ist ein
Machtkampf der Teil der Inflation der im
Moment tatsächlich auf das Bild auf das
Bruttosozialprodukt schlägt ist der Teil
der mit den Tauschverhältnis mit den
Energielieferanten und eine Lebensmittel
Lieferanten globalen Ausmaß zu tun hat
das ein konjunktureller Effekt davon
profitieren z.B die Saudi ist in Katar
dieser Lieferant aber das ist kein kein
kein Urteil für die deutsche Wirtschaft
im im längeren über längeren Zeit hinweg
es ist eine konjunkturelle Effekt der
Effekt einer bestimmten globalen Krise
es gibt bestimmt
Wachstumsprobleme in Deutschland in
Europa insgesamt gibt es schon länger es
gibt ein Problem in der deutschen
Industrie mit dem Standort Deutschlands
als
Industriestandort der unter massiven
Druck gesetzt wird es gibt den
bestimmten Sektoren die für Deutschland
sehr wichtig sind wie zum Beispiel im
Automobilbau aufkommende sorgen in
Sachen e.V und den Wettbewerb dem man
aus China erwartet aber das Ganze
zusammen zu kochen so dass die das
Leiden buchstäblich das Leiden dieser
unteren 20 bis 30 %. dann steht
symbolisch für eine nationale Krise die
dann mit dem mangeln Anreiz für
Leistungsträger oder so etwas zu tun hat
das ist wirklich das ist falsch schon in
dialogisch und man kann diese Probleme
auseinander dividieren man wird
deutschland braucht eine angebrachte und
angemessene finanzierte Sozialpolitik es
kleiner Ermächtigung der Arbeitnehmer es
braucht eine Machtverschiebung die real
ist und von unten anfängt und es braucht
eine Wachstumspolitik und die Inflation
wird meiner Meinung nach sich mit der
Zeit von alleine ergeben aber die diese
drei Probleme in einen Design seinen
Topf zu werfen ist unfair ist unfair und
macht sehr sehr
man wird sich falschen scheiden wenn man
wenn man die Situation so denkt denn es
geht um das auseinander dividieren und
die Probleme in dieser Weise anzugehen
ich bin mit den Herrschaften im Grunde
total einer Meinung dass die
intelförderung nicht sehr
wachstumsversprechend ist die
Arbeitsplätze sind zu teuer und Internet
ist eine Verlierer Firma das ist ja die
Firma den ist ja der ist der erste Platz
von den Taiwanesen aber die wollen wir
auch noch subventionieren
der gesamte Mikrochips Sektor ist meiner
Meinung nach eine sehr schlechte Idee
das ist die Auto Autos
Christen aufmachen der allgemeine Punkt
und der wichtige Punkt ist wirklich
wichtig Wirtschaft anders machen können
dass ich meine dann haben sie die
gesamte Frage gewisser Weise der der
Industriepolitik eine Wachstumspolitik
zentrale Fragen die wir haben es ist
Energiewandel dass ich meine das ist der
zentrale Anliegen das ist
dazuversprechende das ist der
zukunftsversprechende Bereich da sollten
die Investitionen hinein aber nicht
unter der Prämisse dass das viel mit der
inflationsfrage zu tun hat noch
eigentlich mit der sozialen Frage die
die eine Politik für sich brauchte eine
die gleichzeitig mit Geld aber eben auch
mit Machtverschiebung Arbeiten okay dann
fragen wir hier noch mal Herr Kühnert
und
logisch Frau Friedrich nach zehn
Milliarden Investitionen für Intel in
eine Firma von der wir wissen dass es
nicht die top-firma der Chip Hersteller
ist glauben Sie dass das eine kluge
Entscheidung ist 10 Milliarden dahin zu
gehen nach Sachsen-Anhalt das wäre nicht
klug wenn deine Insel wäre und das
einfach nur darum ging irgendeinen
Arbeitsplatz dort zu schaffen aber Intel
erfüllt ja einen anderen Zweck wir
brauchen Chips und moderne Halbleiter in
einer Technologiegesellschaft für
allerlei Produktionsverfahren wenn in
den letzten Jahren die
Produktionsstraßen bei deutschen
Automobilbauern still gestanden haben
dann nicht wegen corona-regeln oder so
sondern weil wir halbleitermangel hatten
die nicht nachgekommen sind und daher
die Autos nicht vom Band laufen konnten
das heißt wir sind hier in dem Bereich
den wir bei unserer China und anderen
Politik mit die risking beschreiben wir
müssen
Abbauen von Komponenten die wir
überwiegend heute aus dem
internationalen Raum holen und die
unsere Leitindustrie wie die
Automobilindustrie und andere ganz
dringend brauchen wir haben bereits Chip
Industrie Schwerpunkt bei Dresden im
Silicon sexy wir werden es jetzt bei
Magdeburg haben übrigens spannend die
haben das dann mehreren Dutzend
Standorten in Europa geprüft Intel und
haben sich für Magdeburg entschieden
weil dort erneuerbare Energien großer
Zahl vorhanden sind und weil dort
leitungsinfrastruktur ist das also auch
wirklich dorthin kommt schöne Grüße zu
Herrn Söder nach Bayern dort siedelt
sich so ein Unternehmen im Moment nicht
an weil das dort nämlich nicht
funktioniert im Moment insofern ist das
schon interessant zu sehen und Intel ist
den in dem Sinne keine Insel sondern ist
Teil einer leitindustriepolitischen
Entscheidung für uns dass wir auf Chip
Industrie auf Wasserstoffwirtschaft auf
batteriezellenproduktion und anderes
mehr in einer modernen Technologiewelt
setzen wollen weil darüber der Wohlstand
von morgen damit auch gute mitbestimmte
Arbeitsplätze verbunden sind davon
überzeugt schon mal den Kopf Frau
Friedrich sie bei solchen Summen muss
man ja sowieso ein bisschen den Kopf
schütteln 3 Millionen wird da ein
Arbeitsplatz subventioniert das ist
jetzt natürlich eigentlich keine
Fachfrage keine wirtschaftsfachfrage
aber in einer solchen Dimension müssen
wir uns dann in wirtschaftspolitischen
Fragen schon bewegen um überhaupt
Deutschland noch attraktiv zu machen und
für andere attraktiv zu sein
also ich würde überhaupt nicht in diesen
abgesangen einstimmen wollen ich würde
mir auch wünschen dass wir wieder das
Bild von dem Land malen dass eine gute
Zukunft hat ich glaube das was sie zu
Beginn gesagt haben wir müssen
investieren in die Dinge die
funktionieren müssen Schienen Straßen
Schulen das ist das was die Menschen
auch belastet und als zweites würde ich
mir tatsächlich wünschen dass wir
schauen wo sollen Mittel hinfließen und
wo nicht ich glaube die Gießkanne und
vielleicht steht da auch diese
Subventionen dafür dass wir unsere
Mittel konzentrieren und wirklich
schauen wem muss geholfen werden und wem
nicht ich weiß nicht ob Intel geholfen
werden muss ich würde erstmal sagen
Familie ich vermutlich nein aber also
ich weiß auf jeden Fall dass wir den
Menschen die arbeiten in diesem Land und
das sind ja viele viele dass die glaube
ich die Diskussion jetzt sind sie
produktiv genug oder nicht wie es die
produktivitätsrate vielleicht mit ein
bisschen Befremden ja heute erlebt haben
weil die Menschen die ich getroffen
getroffen habe Reinigungskräfte
Lieferdienste Leute die verkaufen die
Arbeiten sehr sehr hart und die müssen
wieder ihren Teil bekommen wenn wenn die
ihren Teil beitragen dass sie arbeiten
müssen wir auch ihren Teil unseren Teil
beitragen dass die Hirn vernünftiges
Leben führen können und ich würde mir
wünschen dass das wieder in den Fokus
rückt die letzte Agenda 2010 vielleicht
können wir so schließen weil so begannen
wir ja die Sendung mit einem Angebot von
Herrn Linnemann an Herrn Kühnert darüber
nachzudenken ob die beiden großen
Parteien nicht mal wieder eine neue
Agenda bräuchten eine Agenda 2030 würden
sie eigentlich einschlagen und sagen das
ist ein toller Gedanke wenn man
zusammenarbeitet mit der Opposition sie
können ja jeden Politikern windschießen
der ihn auf die Frage nicht die Antwort
gibt es kommt drauf an was drin steht in
der Agenda die sie machen wollen und ich
glaube ehrlich gesagt die Union wird da
vorher ein paar Fragen für sich klären
müssen wenn ich höre das auf Parteitagen
beschlossen wird man will
industriestrompreisen die
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecherin ist
dafür und Helene Mann der das Programm
schreiben soll sagt er ist gegen den
industriestrompreis also gegen solche
subventionellen die wir besprochen haben
dann haben wir vielleicht nicht zuerst
was miteinander zu besprechen sondern
die Union aber tatsächlich gibt es dazu
nun auch in der Ampel viel zu viel
Widerspruch als dass man das einfach so
durchlaufen könnte ihr einigt euch auf
keine china-strategie einigt euch ich
würde mal sagen vielleicht ist das aber
kein schlechter Gedanke dass es einen
größeren Plan braucht damit die Menschen
wieder ein Ziel haben das klingt
pathetischer als ich es meine es wäre
ganz schön wenn man aus diesem
ungeordneten wir versuchen mal die
Löcher zu stopfen etwas herauskäme und
vielleicht machen wir hier einen Punkt
Teilnehmer man ist nicht traurig dass
wir jetzt sofort live und in Farbe
übergeben zu Markus Lanz der unter
anderem Karl Lauterbach zu Gast hat wir
sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag wieder
gleiche Stelle gleiche Welle und ich
sage Tschüss und ganz herzlichen Dank
diesen Gästen sie dir
[Musik]